let me pull up this story from the hill
GOP rep Thomas Massey endorses DeSantis
for 2024. that's it that's the story he
said America needs a leader who is
decisive respects the Constitution
understands policy puts Family First and
leads by inspiring that's why I'm
endorsing Ron DeSantis for president if
we make the right choices America's best
days are in front of us let's pick a
proven energetic leader who can get us
there he continued let's choose Ron
DeSantis for president that means that
Donald Trump is going to knock
representative Thomas Massey down to a
fifth rate
well so uh I I've talked Ad nauseam
about my views on DeSantis I think he's
fantastic I really do think he's done a
great job in Florida I don't know if I
would uh at this point right now vote
for him over Trump I'm curious Dave what
you think about Matthew's endorsement
and DeSantis well I mean look you know
I'm not exactly sure first off Thomas
Massey is the best Congressman in the
country so just yeah I give him a lot of
credit and look Thomas Massey was the
one who stood up in real time while the
kovid emergency was going on and said
this is insane to just be giving away
two trillion dollars in corporate
bailouts with no type of like vote no
audit of what's going on and he was
completely demonized by by Donald Trump
at the time Donald Trump really sent all
of his sycophants after Massey which is
a horrible thing to do Messi was 100
right this is what create not only like
really created so much of the
instability we have today but so much of
the price inflation that people have
been suffering under for the last couple
years was due to these monstrous
spending bills in 2020. so I also
understand why Massey maybe isn't the
biggest fan of Donald Trump I was with
Trump on that back during the uh the
shutdowns but I think it's fair to say
that hindsight is 20 20. and I think you
know my view of it back then was
there's videos of people collapsing in
the street we don't know a whole lot
maybe we just need to stem the bleed of
the economic you know problems now and
then try and figure out what's going on
looking back on all of it yeah I think
Thomas Massey was completely right well
that's the best I can do that's fair
enough
um I I think that the the thing is like
if you understand the nature of how the
federal government like like bills like
this work you just know it's just it's
not as if there's ever any real like oh
the people are hurting so we need Aid
it's just a race of lobbyists everyone
getting their little special thing in
there and then you're lucky if the
American people get like some crumbs on
it but anyway but I'll just say that I
do think look it's hard it's hard to
deny that even though he wasn't very
good at the very beginning that what
DeSantis did in Florida for uh for coved
was just so much better than almost
every other governor in the country I
guess Christy gnome is the exception to
that I think she never had any mandates
or lockdowns or anything but South
Dakota is not Florida and Florida is a
much bigger state with an old population
and he really put all of his chips in
and a very dangerous time on We're not
gonna go to Tyrion here in Florida and
it paid off and so I understand where
there's there's a reason why he flipped
a purple State into a 20-point red State
you know I mean it's it's you you have
to acknowledge that and the mass Exodus
from these blue States into Florida
because of his leadership so the
question then becomes DeSantis or Trump
now obviously I know you know you're
probably a more libertarian guy but
based like let's let's isolate this to
the GOP Primary who do you think would
be better for the Republicans
well for the Republicans and just it's
real clear to presence it's not again
because I was trying to say this last
time I was on the show it's not like I'm
saying like the it's like well the I'm
not making the perfect the enemy of the
good I'm not saying like I understand
Republicans both uh Trump or DeSantis
would be much better than Joe Biden in a
lot of ways my thing is that I think
America is going to die like I think
this is a patient who's bleeding out and
you're like well a Band-Aid is better
than not a Band-Aid and I'm like no he
will still die we need like a a like a
revolutionary moment here to drastically
cut the the size of the scope of
government I will say for uh from the
repo what you asked me from the
Republican perspective as of right now I
gotta say I just don't I don't really
see any metric by which DeSantis is
better for the Republicans Donald Trump
has as I've known when I've like argued
with you about my criticisms of Donald
Trump I had a debate with uh sticks
about this and I've heard back from lot
of the Trump supporters and I don't even
mean this is a knock on them but there
is a bit of a uh Cult of Personality
going on there they if you're if
DeSantis goes to war with Donald Trump
which it'll have to be in order for him
to like challenge him for the nomination
there I don't think Trump's people will
fall in line with DeSantis I think
they're Trump or bust and I think the
only guy the Republican the Republicans
have who can actually put that Coalition
together whether that's enough to win I
don't know but I think it's Trump
there's probably a lot of moderates who
would vote for Descendants but wouldn't
vote for Trump there's a lot of people
will not vote for Trump yeah there might
there might be some I I mean that's
probably true you know the other thing
DeSantis is such a big question mark on
his foreign policy and he was really bad
as a congressman on this issue well
let's celebrate on that because I've
heard people say he was good oh no I
mean he well good if you're like you
know like good if you think like George
W bush had great foreign policy then
sure but no he was a he was a complete
hawk in every sense of the word he was
uh he was like on board with every one
of the military like uh actions that he
could have been while he was in Congress
now that doesn't matter so much when
you're governor of Florida and when
you're governor of Florida your covid
policy is like a hell of a lot more
important than where you stand on the
wars but when you're the president of
the United States the most important
thing is where you stand on the wars
that's the one area where you're like
the dictator and so that's that's a big
deal so about a year ago in reference to
your Cult of Personality thing with
people who have argued about a year ago
I was I was totally on board for
DeSantis and I said you know Trump's
whining and he won't shut up about 2020
and I'm not interested that was rough to
listen to too and so I'm just like and
then here's the scientist who's coming
and clean up cleaning up all these
Messes in in Florida and doing a great
job now over the past several months
I've seen something else Donald Trump
has cleaned up his messaging he's come
out he's talked about the war machine
he's talked about the Deep State the
economy he's made these videos where
he's like my policy will be to do this
thing and I'm like these are good he
shows up in East Palestine he buys
everybody McDonald's which was human and
endearing and I really liked it but more
importantly he's gotten back to the I
will crush the Deep State and Execute
Order schedule F and Ron DeSantis to me
when this is important because this was
a this is a critical moment for me
when they said they wanted to indict
Trump and Ron DeSantis two times said
I'm not getting involved in this I was
like I can't vote for that guy I think
he's great I think he's great if I was
in Florida I'd vote for him for governor
as president the guy whose attitude is I
don't look at me I'm not getting
involved is like are you kidding me dude
we need Donald Trump to go in and fire
everyone and DeSantis showed me right
there he's more likely to be the guy who
goes in and says how can we work
together yeah the FBI needs to be
reformed or something like that yeah
Trump's going to be like I want revenge
well he might I mean that that very
likely might be the case although Donald
Trump has been wronged by people and
then worked with them and and endorsed
and supported or even appointed them
before so I don't know I'm not that
confident I will say what really
bothered me with the Ron DeSantis thing
was that he walked back the somewhat
good comments he had made about the war
in Ukraine
um I think there's it's an interesting
Dynamic here where you have say like the
Republican Party Republican
establishment is completely on board
with this with this war this proxy war
of choice on the border of the country
with the biggest nuclear Arsenal in the
history of the world the most insane
policy imaginable and you got Mitch
McConnell is wearing like a Ukraine
lapel pen Mitch McConnell said the
number one issue the number one priority
as this country is crumbling is that we
keep supporting Ukraine uh and so it's
it was kind of interesting to see now
Donald Trump's coming out and saying
telling the truth which is that this is
we should just be negotiating toward
peace right now this is insane that
we're fighting this proxy war
um DeSantis kind of came out and kind of
said like well I don't know if it's
exactly a vital that we do this and then
seem to kind of walk those comments back
to me if there's gonna be one compelling
case to vote for anybody
uh it would be who is going to end this
insanity this game of brinksmanship that
has brought us closer to nuclear war
than at any point at least since the
Cuban Missile Crisis the libertarian
party
should any one of their potential
candidates we'll just put it that way
very very vaguely uh should any one of
their candidates become the president do
you think they will execute schedule F
schedule F we have firing all the
bureaucrats I I think that yes I mean
look
so unless you have look a lot of things
have to happen in order for that to
happen but let's say if the libertarian
candidate for president wins the
presidency then there has already been a
major shift in this country right like
something huge has happened where a
whole bunch of people have gone hey
we're going to completely rethink the
way we think about politics right now
and we like this guy who's talking about
giving us more of a free country so
there would be there would be a
tremendous mandate behind that person
unlike any Republican or Democrat could
have if they had one because so many
people are just voting for their party
and so yeah now I would say
um of course that's what we would do
you'd probably want to do it in a
strategically smart way you know I would
be a little bit concerned about I
wouldn't take any convertible rides
through Dallas the day after I uh gave
that order can I say I I want to make a
request to the people who are listening
because I don't have the means to do
this but could somebody take the scene
from Star Wars when the emperor says
that order you know Execute Order 66 and
just make it Trump in a cloak and use
the 11 Labs AI voice deep fake
technology to make Trump say execute
schedule F and then just show a whole
bunch of bureaucrats being like let out
of offices with empty boxes and stuff
like that well it'll be well it plays
the very serious medic
I just the problem with Trump is at
least say the first time he was
President I never saw anything out of
them that convinced me that he would
actually follow through with something
that bold and every time he flirted
around with doing something really bold
he walked it back he oh they whoever got
in the room with him whatever they
convinced them or lied to him or
threatened him or whatever it was he
always said he hired the absolute best
guy that you should hire who should have
been his defense secretary from day one
but he hired Colonel Douglas McGregor uh
to come in and draw up the plans to end
these wars and he hired him after he
lost the election to Joe Biden so they
had just this little lame duck period to
work with Colonel Douglas McGregor draws
up the the um the order to end the war
in Afghanistan and Syria and pull all
troops out Donald Trump signs it and the
next day he rescinded the offer hey it
rescinded the order excuse me now I
don't know who got in the room with them
I don't know she's listening to his
idiot uh friend Lindsey Graham or he's
listening to his idiot son-in-law I
don't know who it was but one way or the
other that's what happened and Donald
Trump would say the right things about
like sometimes on kovid but he'd never
really do it and I also I'll also just
never forgive him for uh for keeping
fauci on the job through all of 2020.
mocking Sweden for not locking down you
know like it was I just like the
funniest thing ever to me would be if
like there's a dramatic political shift
in the next year where people are like
you know moderate say I just don't want
to vote for Trump then Along Comes This
more uh personable relatable libertarian
candidate who's preaching all of these
things and then the moment that
libertarian gets in office he starts
bombing a bunch of foreign countries
whoa she goes guys and then like people
like like Phil's like dude what are you
doing like you made all these promises I
go hey dude you want to be the head of
Raytheon
I can get you a pretty sweet gig I go I
don't know it just looks a lot different
from the inside than it was from the
outside it Phil's on the show and he's
like I can't believe we are betrayed by
this guy but I'm gonna be sitting down
to talk with some sense into him and
then the next day it's like he's wearing
a suit and he was like you are all wrong
about the war and you hate America yeah
Phil did you always have Diamond contact
you know I wouldn't talk about a new job
but there would be signs there would be
signs thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time